hi veronica
hi steve
today i'm gonna talk with veronica mark
of moscow about just how much can you
learn on your own
in a
place where the language you're learning
is not spoken now remember if you enjoy
these videos please subscribe click on
the bell for notifications if you follow
me on a podcast please leave a review i
appreciate it so hello veronica hi
we are going to speak in english because
veronica's english is amazing absolutely
amazing
and veronica has a webs our youtube
channel called
english with veronica or with veronica
mark
which is not with veronica with veronica
mark yeah you're right with veronica
martin okay
and we just had a conversation in
english
and
her english is i would say flawless
floss now
when i say
i would mistake her for a native speaker
not quite but almost
and the use of words the way you put
words together is completely native
speaker
uh intonation everything there's just
very few little things that give you
away but what i find very interesting
with veronica is you have basically
lived your whole life in moscow correct
yeah in russia yeah i i'm not from
moscow so i lived yeah i lived in a
different city
until i was uh 17 and then i moved to
moscow yeah okay
so we often hear people say you know to
learn the language really well you have
to move to the country
where the language is spoken and so
forth and so on and you are living proof
that that's not necessary so how did you
go about achieving such a high level of
english without really leaving russia
yeah so thank you for your question uh
when i was in school like in russia it's
mandatory for every student for every
kid to start learning english at school
as a as the first foreign language
and obviously when i was a kid like i
was eight years old i didn't really care
about foreign languages at all and for
me it was just another subject that i
didn't like
and i feel like the moment that i
realized that i actually really enjoyed
english was when i was 16
it was my
yeah i think i was in high school my
junior year in high school and i was
just so excited to learn to start
learning english
and first of all i only focused on the
input i was just listening to something
reading books just first i started with
some stupid books for kids because for
me it was really entertaining and they
were actually really interesting
and
i had a i had an english teacher she was
russian so but she had a very good level
of english and she helped me a lot she
was always motivating me and she she was
just amazing and i'm really grateful for
her
and
then there was time when i had to
prepare to go to college i had to take
some tests and exams and i decided to
take english as my exam because in
russia we can choose
so
and then
that is when i really had to prepare
well
and but obviously when you prepare for a
test it's a little bit different than
what you actually need like to
communicate with people or to just read
something in english
and when i moved to moscow this is when
i realized that
i really lacked
just
yeah i had a lot of things that i didn't
know like culture wise and just
vocabulary my vocabulary wasn't really
as great and
one of my professors english professors
told me that i should really look into
accents
and think about because my english was
already pretty good and there was one
thing that she said could be better
which is my pronunciation
because sometimes i mixed up accents i
would say something in a british accent
and then
another world would be an american
accent and then my russian accent
obviously
would be also there
and this is when i i was like okay now i
need to really think about improving my
accent and i try to focus more on the
american accent and this is when i
learned all those rules
of connected speech
of yeah all of those different sounds in
the american english
and obviously still every single day i
focus on the input because i just read a
lot in english i love reading in any
language really so for me it was just
natural to start reading in english
and i really loved listening to podcasts
so i should point out too that so you
speak english you speak chinese
what other languages do you speak uh
french at a beginner level yeah at a
beginner level yeah and you're chinese
is how would you classify it oh
intermediate sometimes when i practice
more operated media yeah
okay
and so basically when you were very
young you weren't that interested and
then at the age of 16 you become you you
became very interested yeah very
interesting and uh
it's interesting a lot of parents they
want their kids to learn languages
english in many cases
and so this sort of they want to expose
their kids to as much english as
possible when they're three years old or
something they really push this early
immersion and my experience has been
that if if the kid is interested that's
fine but if the kid isn't interested
don't push yeah because it's never too
late if somebody gets motivated at age
16 they will they will go and learn yeah
and and at the other end of the spectrum
you have countries like sweden where all
of the television programs are in
english who shouldn't say they're all in
english but they're in the original
version so if it's an american
television program or a british
television program all the kids are
going to watch that in the original
version so swedish kids without even
trying they show up at school they
already have a fairly decent
level in english just through all of
that input but you would not have had
that because in russia you would not
have heard so much english on television
no definitely not
no so you would have to make a special
effort to get that input
through whatever you can find on the
internet and so forth
uh
so the podcast that you listen to is
that mostly for pronunciation is it for
vocabulary
uh how much opportunity did you have to
use the language
um i think right now and when i was like
16 or i don't know 18
i
primarily focused more okay when i was
like 16 18 i focused more on the
podcasts that actually taught english
they were yeah the hosts were native
speakers of for example like american
english and they would explain some
expressions in english they would talk
about the culture and it was really
interesting to me but right now i
never listen to these podcasts anymore i
just listened to podcasts for native
speakers news i love listening to the
news sometimes and just some interesting
podcasts about
anything really anything i'm interested
in is it easier to find i presume it's
easier to find the content of interest
in english than in chinese for example
or not maybe there's lots in chinese i'm
not learning chinese right now so i
don't know maybe there's lots of stuff
out there it's easier i would say it's
easier and faster to
to
find some new content in english than in
chinese but if you know where to look
then it's no problem finding anything in
chinese so if a person wants to achieve
a high level in the language
without having the opportunity to travel
to where the language is spoken even
though that might be a long-term goal to
go to the country where the language is
spoken
that there is a lot that they can do on
their own and that it's possible to
achieve a very high level
and what do you think are the the main
ingredients in in order to to be
successful
in order to achieve a high level in a
language
uh without having the opportunity to be
in the country what what are the what
would you say if you had to name say
three things that are essential in order
to be successful what would they be
being consistent is definitely going to
be one of them and i think it applies to
everything we do in life not just
learning a language yeah if you want to
be good at sports you need to be
consistent too
so yeah would be consistency
focusing on the input
and i think the third one is also going
to be about something about not
stressing too much not worrying too much
because the thoughts we have in our head
sometimes for example
it didn't help me at all when i was
younger to think that my english was not
good that i couldn't communicate with
people because i would always feel
scared and not ready to talk to other
people
so yeah definitely the thoughts we have
our mental state is really important too
well you know i completely agree with
you uh
we've got to give ourselves credit for
what we achieve and not criticize
ourselves because we can always improve
but we all we will also continue making
mistakes and having things we don't
understand and none of that matters if
we want it to be a hundred percent
comfortable we stay in our native
language yeah anytime we're speaking in
another language it's it's less
comfortable but it's more fun yeah and
and i think you're
proof that
great things can be achieved even if
you're not surrounded by the language
so thank you i hope that your example
can encourage people
and
if we have
as i do have viewers who are not native
speakers of english
they may want to check out your youtube
channel
english with veronica mark
and i'm sure they'll find many useful
tips as well as lots of encouragement so
thank you very much and good luck in
your language learning journeys thank
you so much okay thank you
bye-bye bye